I've always been skeptical of the notion
that the liberal media are full of
until I saw the Mad vitriol with which
the media have been attacking Jim
caviezel's new movie about child sex
trafficking the sound of freedom
this film is being marketed to either
specific Q Anon Believers or to people
who believe all of the same tenets as Q
Anon but claim they don't know what it
is
and the sound of Freedom does focus on a
real issue of sex trafficking but that
theme it's sort of like that kernel of
truth that feeds the Q Anon conspiracy
theory tell us how those two things work
together
sure and the most durable and the most
believable conspiracy theories are not
entirely false there's something in them
that is true and the rest of it is false
but the Believers point to the one true
thing and they say oh you don't believe
that this particular thing is true in
terms of child trafficking we know
trafficking is real we know it has real
victims no one is denying that but these
films are created out of moral panics
they're created out of bogus statistics
they're created out of fear and with
something like sound of Freedom it
specifically is looking at keyword on
concepts of these child trafficking
rings that are run by the high-level
Elites the Q Anon Q Anon Q Anon the libs
are Furious the movie hit over 18
million dollars in its box office
opening six days ago it's already
grossed over 40 million within a week it
is a certified hit so desperate to
convince people to stop seeing it the
media are now trying to link the movie
to Q Anon Washington Post quote sound of
freedom is a box office hit whose star
races Q Anon the guardian sound of
Freedom the Q Anon adjacent Thriller
seducing America and rolling stone sound
of freedom is a superhero movie for dads
with brain worms the Q a non-tinged
thriller about child trafficking is
designed to appeal to the conscience of
a conspiracy adult Boomer now I don't
know much about Q Anon the only people I
ever hear really talk about Q Anon are
the liberal media I run in lots of
conservative circles all over the
country I don't hear about it I turn on
CNN for five seconds it's all they talk
about
but what's really strange about this
coverage
is that the movie is based on a true
story it's the story of how a real guy
Tim Ballard rescued kids from sex
trafficking
so the libs are saying that a true story
an indisputably true story is q a
non-adjacent
which means some people really do
believe in Q Anon
the liberal media who spent the whole
weekend inadvertently insisting that the
theory is true I'm Michael Knowles this
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show what a weekend
we we saw the criminal complaint against
the anarchists who tried to blow me up
at Pittsburgh I was hosting a where I
was appearing at a campus event at the
University of Pittsburgh there was lots
of Madness around it and the school
tried to shut it down and the
legislators tried to shut it down and I
knew that there were some wackos on the
street setting me on fire and Effigy and
all that kind of stuff I didn't realize
until I read this criminal complaint
from the doj just how serious it was so
we'll get to that in one second first
though I don't I don't want to move on
too fast from
the liberal Fury that Jim Caviezel and
Tim Ballard are exposing pedo Rings
because they're saying it's all a crazy
conspiracy theory
is it the Q Anon about which I know
pretty much nothing to Anon from what I
can tell is this crazy conspiracy theory
that there is an elite pedophile ring
that involves some of the wealthiest and
most influential people in the world
and just
apropos of nothing uh here is an
interview that has recently come out
from one of Jeffrey Epstein's victims
I have uh spent the last 17 years in My
Own Prison
for what she Jeffrey and all the
co-conspirators did to me I was raped
repeatedly I was raped three times a day
sometimes
and I was not the only girl on that
island there was a constant stream of
girls being raped over and over and over
again and yes Guillain must die in
prison because I've been in Hull and
back for the last 17 years
seven for me I was 10 years old
when Liz Stein was being trafficked I
was 10. that is how long the sex
trafficking ring has been going on for
what is the claim of the liberal media
here
they just slapped this label Q Anon Q
Anon whatever that is the thing that
you've only ever heard about from the
liberal media
but what are they actually saying
they're
denying the existence of sex trafficking
no you heard the CNN lady admit no sex
driving is a real problem are they not
denying the existence of elite sex
trafficking Rings they probably are
because the liberal media tried to kill
the Jeffrey Epstein story but we know
the Jeffrey Epstein story is real we
know that Jeffrey Epstein was Palling
around with the most powerful people on
Earth Prime Ministers presidents
royalty major financiers heads of
Industry we know that he had his own
James Bond villain-esque private island
in the Caribbean where he was bringing
an endless slew of young girls he was
partnering with with major modeling
head honchos and bringing these young
girls through the island to engage in
weird sex stuff with the most
influential people in the world so then
then we know that Jeffrey Epstein was
arrested and mysteriously killed himself
after multiple cameras malfunctioned and
multiple jail employees just forgot to
do their job or fell asleep on the job
what's the conspiracy theory
I don't here's the here's the only
conspiracy that that
we haven't really solved yet all of it
is so far in the open the question is
who's in Jeffrey Epstein's black book
isn't that kind of weird isn't it weird
that we started to prosecute Jeffrey
Epstein we did prosecute Elaine Maxwell
and we still don't know who his clients
were
don't expect to hear about that on the
the liberal media we're not even talking
about a regular sex trafficking ring
like you see in the sound of Freedom
movie which is a very good movie by the
way I watched the movie in an advanced
screener it's very good I'm not
surprised that it's doing huge box
office numbers not surprised that the
libs hate it so much
but I'm no I guess I am surprised that
they hate it so I'm not surprised that
they hate it I'm surprised they hate it
so much I'm surprised that they are
willing to show their hand this much
that they're not only willing to to
cover for Jeffrey Epstein and downplay
that story and kill that story when
different reporters wanted to to bring
it to public attention but now they're
trying to downplay the existence of sex
trafficking entirely
they're saying oh that's Q Anon that's Q
Anon
maybe maybe everything that people have
said about the liberal media maybe it's
right now when you want to protect your
society as Things Fall Apart you want to
protect your wealth you got to check out
Birch gold right now text Knowles Canada
wlas to 98 98 98 as central banks in
countries such as China India and
Australia begin looking to transition to
a digital currency the Federal Reserve
has been contemplating the same for the
U.S with a digital currency the
government could track every single
purchase you make officials could even
prohibit you from purchasing certain
products officials could easily freeze
or seize part or all of your money Times
Like These are a great reminder to
diversify a portion of your savings into
gold you can do that with the help of
Birch gold they are who I get my gold
from so do thousands of other concerned
Savers Birch gold will help you convert
an existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in
Gold you don't pay a penny out of pocket
when currencies fail gold is a safe
haven how much more time does the dollar
or have protect your savings with gold
Birch gold has an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers text Knowles kwles to 98
98 98 get your free info kit on gold if
a central bank digital currency becomes
a reality it will be nice to have some
gold to depend upon text Knowles Canada
wies to 98 98 98 major culture win for
the right this movie sound of Freedom
another major culture win for the right
the hits just keep on coming for Bud
Light
Sizer Bush Bud Light is now out of the
top 10 American beers took another hit
in the ratings there was a yougov survey
of the top 10 beers in America Bud Light
had previously been number nine
so it's the number one best-selling beer
in America and then in popular opinion
it was the number nine favorite beer
it's now dropped down to 14. it hasn't
bottomed out yet I think we're gonna
have to introduce a segment on the show
which is the Bud Light update because
Bud Light thought they could weather the
storm it would take a week or two their
their market cap would drop but then
they would rebound no big deal they
wouldn't have to apologize they wouldn't
have to address anything they could just
blow past their embracing of
and that hasn't happened but like
continues to drop in sales in popularity
it hasn't bottomed out yet so we have to
introduce this new segment
it'll be we probably will have to do it
off of YouTube because you're not
allowed to talk about important issues
on YouTube anymore so maybe we'll have
to do it over a daily wire plus if
you're not a member there if you're not
uh watching at the YouTube channel or
rather at the the Twitter Channel Make
sure you do that at M knoll's show now
speaking of wins we had some legal wins
too also on the topic
and
[Music]
again
speaking of
major cultural shifts this is really
great news it's coming out of NBC
headline conservative influencers are
pushing an anti-birth control message
alarmist statements about hormonal birth
control go viral on social media but
experts say they're not showing the full
picture who are the experts because the
the conservative influencers who are
pushing the anti-birth control message
I'm sorry to say I'm not included in
this article I wish I'm pushing an
anti-birth control message but I'm not
included in the article and the reason
is the article is focused almost
entirely on women
focusing on Alex Clark over there at TP
USA focusing on Ashley Saint Claire
who's a conservative influencer focusing
on let's say how many others I won't I
won't go through and reread the entire
article but focusing on a lot of these
conservative gals who are saying yeah I
was on birth control I'm not I'm not
being specific to Alex Clark and Ashley
Sinclair I don't know about their
specific experience with birth control
but there are a lot of conservative
women who say I was on birth control and
it messed me up and I went kind of crazy
and maybe I had fertility problems as a
result of it and the more studies I read
about this the more I realized that
there are serious risks to birth control
and I promise you if you're listening to
this show right now you've either
experienced this or you it really know
somebody who's experienced these kind of
questions and who are now raising doubts
about birth control
and the libs hate this
the libs hate that we're we're moving
toward a less contraceptive society and
it's not just on the pill or the patch
or the devices that young girls are
persuaded to to insert into themselves
so that they can be used by men to have
casual sex without without getting
married without having children without
any consequences for it it's beyond
mirror birth control
the same people who were Furious that
conservative women are pushing against
birth control are also Furious that the
Supreme Court made it a little bit
harder to kill babies through abortion
they're the same people who are pushing
euthanasia for the elderly and the poor
and the homeless and the mentally ill
they're the same people who are pushing
the sterilization of children through
all these eunuch making procedures that
they called
it's all the same thing and I can't help
but notice
the end is always the same which is
fewer people
because these guys the leftists the
sexual revolutionaries
who are pushing all of these social
pathologies
they just seem to hate people or at the
very least they're being used by vessels
of entities that hate people it's always
the same end and it's a reminder for
conservatives you know there were a lot
of conservatives who would argue and
pro-lifers they would say look we just
want to end abortion we're not going to
touch contraception we're not going to
touch uh
I don't know artificial insemination
we're not going to touch IVF we're not
going to touch surrogacy we're not going
to touch this that or the other thing
and I understand tactically why they say
the killing of babies in the womb is is
much more urgent and dire and dangerous
than these other issues but you can't
neatly separate all of these issues
it's it's all of a piece with the sexual
Revolution
the the culture that treats sex very
casually and that suggests that we have
a right to sex absent the consequence of
pregnancy is going to be a culture
that's more likely to engage in abortion
the culture that Embraces radical
individualism and selfishness and
libertinism
in one area of sexual matters is going
to embrace it in another and that's
going to result in abortion and
furthermore
we're all complaining about the pride
movement and the pride movement has
become much less popular than it used to
be you're seeing this in a drop Gallop
polling and the values survey that it
gives out showed a significant drop in
support for the pride Coalition in just
one year so a lot of people are turning
on it a lot of mothers a lot of parents
in schools that's how Glenn youngin won
in Virginia that's how Ron DeSantis one
of Florida
well I think people now are beginning to
look back
and they're saying look it's not just
the kids more broadly this was the point
of my seat back speech and it's not just
it's the redefinition of marriage and
it's not just the redefinition of
marriage it's the way that we View
sex
why did Gallup show seven point drop in
support for same-sex relations of any
kind because people are beginning to
pull on the thread of the kids and
realizing that because ideas have
consequences bad consequences come from
bad ideas and so they're going all the
way back and forget redefining marriage
or whatever you go all the way back to
the beginning of the sexual Revolution
and you go all the way back to
contraception there were two cases
eisenstadt and Griswold first was
Griswold in 1965 then eisenstead comes
around in 1972 the year before Roe v
Wade and Griswold finds a right to
condoms within a marriage where is that
in the Constitution I have no idea but
some Libs on the court discovered that
magically in 1965. but they said but
there is no right to condoms outside of
marriage then seven years later the
court discovers oh actually there was
more invisible ink in the Constitution
and actually there is a right to condoms
outside of marriage okay maybe you like
condoms maybe you don't like condoms I
don't know where you're going to find
that in the Constitution I think a lot
of people are beginning to notice
that the contraceptive mentality is the
beginning of the pride mentality because
the contraceptive mentality divorces sex
from the consequences of sex
it introduces a sterile
sexual ethic
which is exactly what gave us the pride
movement there there's no distinction
here
if you can't read between the lines the
conclusion that one draws is that
condoms are kind of gay
to put it as bluntly as possible okay
and it's not a coincidence that female
conservative influencers noticed by NBC
News
are beginning to pick up on that
bad ideas can have a very long run
but eventually and this is the
conservative consolation reality
reasserts itself in the end and people
are beginning to realize okay if I don't
like this insane anarchistic view of sex
that is totally self-centered and
divorced from any ends whatsoever
well then maybe I got to rewind it and
ask what is the point
of sex
just why it's not going to be the
patriarchy that's coming for you
consequence rebirth control it's not
going to be the men it's the men frankly
are huge supporters of of birth control
and contraception because it allows them
to have consequence free sex
it's going to be those conservative
women that's who's coming for it NBC
News is right to be worried now speaking
of the Boudoir how are you sleeping
maybe you want to check out
Helix sleep right now I go to
helixsleep.com Knowles with everything
going on in the world right now you
could really use a good night's sleep
that is why you got to check out Helix
mattress he likes his harnessed years of
extensive mattress expertise to bring
their customers a truly elevated sleep
experience they just launched their new
Helix Elite the Helix Elite collection
includes six different mattress models
each tailored for specific sleep
positions and firmness preferences I've
had my Helix for about three years now I
absolutely adore this bed night after
night I sleep like a sweet little baby I
want the same for you Helix has a sleep
quiz that matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress because why would you buy a
mattress that was made for someone else
why do you want to get into my mattress
huh I'm a married guy you need to get
your own mattress go to helixsleep.com
take their two-minute sleep quiz to find
the perfect mattress for your body and
sleep type their flexible payment plans
make it so that a great night's sleep is
never far away Helix is offering 20 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for my listeners hurry on over to
helixsleep.com Knowles with Helix better
sleep starts
now when Dr Jordan B Peterson made the
decision to join daily wire plus it was
a major win for those who championed
free speech and intellectual debate with
one year of unparalleled output his
contributions have set new standards and
remained unmatched by any other platform
daily wire plus now has a vast array of
exclusive Jordan Peterson content
offering hundreds of hours of
captivating content you won't find
anywhere else Jordan has created
thought-provoking works that reshape
your perspective on life which include
vision and Destiny marriage and Dragons
monsters and men Additionally you can
immerse yourself in discussions that
nurture your spiritual side such as
logos and literacy and Jordan's
groundbreaking series on the book of
Exodus that's only the beginning I
haven't even mentioned his Beyond order
lecture series or his extensive Archive
of lectures and podcasts this is the
absolute compendium of all things Jordan
plus there's even more new exclusive
content on the horizon this is only the
beginning by becoming a daily wire plus
member you will embark on an
unforgettable experience that will fuel
your thirst for now knowledge and
Inspire personal growth like never
before go to dailywear.com subscribe to
become a member today
speaking of the sexual Revolution
major pop culture story that I am being
forced to know about
because that's how social media works I
would not oh
I barely know who Jonah Hill is
I did not know that Jonah Hill and Seth
Rogen were different people until about
three years ago
and I've just they're different people
now Seth Rogen is a huge lib Jonah Hill
I assume is a big lib too but
I actually think based on the leaked
text messages that are creating a huge
Hollywood Tempest in a teapot
Jonah Hill might be one of the most
normal people in Hollywood
what came out was a series of private
text messages leaked by Jonah Hill's
ex-girlfriend portraying him as an
emotionally abusive monster
this after Jonah Hill announces that
he's had a baby with his girlfriend so
he's not married he should marry his
girlfriend uh they've just had a baby
and this ex-girlfriend of something like
two years ago releases text messages and
this is what she says is an example of
emotional abuse
Jonah texts her and says quote
plain and simple if you need surfing
with men boundaryless inappropriate
friendships with men to model to post
pictures of yourself in a bathing suit
to post sexual pictures friendships with
women who are in unstable places and
from your wild recent past Beyond
getting a lunch or coffee or something
respectful I'm not the right partner for
you if these things bring you to a place
of happiness I support it and there will
be no hard feelings these are my
boundaries for romantic partnership my
boundaries with you based on the ways
these actions have hurt our trust
yeah
that's it
that's the that's the the example of an
emotionally abusive this is one of the
most mature
romantic treatises I've read in our
entire popular media it's not perfect I
don't like the idea of talking about
romance as a partnership we're just
we're in a partnership and I don't I
don't like the idea of divorcing romance
from the end of marriage and children
all the rest of it but what he's saying
here is yeah look if you wanna
if you want to have boundary less
inappropriate friendships with men I
don't like that I'm going to be a little
bit jealous just as you would be jealous
of me if I were at an appropriate
boundaryless relationships with women
and I I don't like the idea that you've
got to post skimpy pictures of yourself
on the internet if you want to do that
you can go do that I won't be angry at
you but that's not
that's not going to work for me and I if
we're going to move towards something
like marriage I I just don't want my
wife to be doing that and
I I don't want you to put yourself in
the
near occasion of sin and you know I
wouldn't do that myself either and I'm
not I'm not yelling at you I'm not being
angry I'm not threatening you in any way
you can go your own way it'll be totally
fine I'm just telling you that's that's
where I am
that's very reasonable
the only thing that he hasn't done is he
he should man up even further and say by
the way here's my this is my framework
not only for over relationship but for
marriage and then we can get married and
we can do what married couples do and we
can have kids and have a nice family and
it'll be a good life
totally totally right she responds to
all of this and she says I hope my ex
Joan hill has a daughter maybe she'll
turn him into a real feminist because
the fact that he calls himself a
feminist now is laughable and she that's
the one part she's right about Jonah
Hill is obviously not a feminist he
might pretend to be a feminist he might
dress up like a lib and use the language
of a lib but he's not he's not a
feminist he's a he's a relatively normal
guy
his ex-girlfriend obviously is a
feminist feminism is wrong
you should reject it men women anybody
in between that supposedly exists
nowadays
reject it it's just the problem with
feminism is not that it gives women too
much power or whatever feminism doesn't
give women any power it deprives women
of their power it's just wrong the
problem with feminism
as is the problem with so many modern
ideologies
is that it posits a false anthropology a
false conception of human nature and so
when conservatives invade against
feminism it's not because we hate women
quite the opposite it's because we love
women and it doesn't even come from any
sort of passion or any sort of personal
desire or anything like that it comes
from a rational
deduction and empirical observation of
human nature
and saying oh feminism says a woman
needs a man like a fish needs a bicycle
feminism says that women and men are
pretty much the same and I just know
that that isn't true and so if you
pursue feminism
you're going to be miserable and unhappy
like Jonah Hill's ex-girlfriend and if
you don't pursue feminism and you pursue
normal life and you you recognize that
the Sexes are complementary rather than
indiscernible you're gonna have a better
life who seems to be doing better right
now Jonah Hill or the ex-girlfriend the
rest of my case now
speaking of Wars not just Wars between
the Sexes but Wars around the world
the Biden Administration has decided to
send cluster bombs to Ukraine what are
cluster bombs a lot of people don't know
what it is and the moment that any novel
or somewhat obscure concept hits the
headlines all of a sudden everybody's an
expert on it they're all armchair
experts who you know attended naval war
college or something like that cluster
bombs are a particularly dangerous type
of munition
that will will blanket a space with with
explosives that have a fairly High fail
rate and so what that means is if you
drop a bunch of cluster Munitions all
over the countryside a lot of them might
not go off and so even years after the
close of a conflict you have a lot of
civilians and farmers and travelers
getting blown up by these kinds of
Munitions this is why Jen Saki
last year as White House Press Secretary
suggested that cluster bombs might
constitute a war crime
there are reports of illegal cluster
bombs and vacuum bombs being used by the
Russians if that's true what is the next
step of this Administration and is there
a red line for how much violence uh will
be tolerated against civilians in this
manner that's illegal and potentially a
war crime it is it would be I don't have
any confirmation of that we have seen
the reports uh if if that were true it
would potentially be a war crime
obviously there are a range of
international fora that would assess
that so certainly we would look to that
to be a part of that conversation
so cluster bombs
intrinsically
might constitute a war crime
and when jensaki was asked about that it
was in the context the hypothetical of
Russia using cluster bombs
oh yes that might very well be a work
run
now we are sending cluster bombs to
Ukraine that's not that's not either Joe
Biden is admitting that he's a war
criminal
or we're saying no no when we do it it's
not a war crime
and the most honest liberals the most
honest proponents of the war in Ukraine
are going to make that argument they're
going to say it's a war crime when
Russia does this type of thing but it's
not a war crime when America does this
type of thing and it's probably going to
be a difficult argument to make but
maybe somebody can make it
we need that kind of clarity
this has been a major shift in politics
in my lifetime
it's been a Reckoning with American
foreign policy that was pretty much on
autopilot since World War II
finally now people on the left and on
the right are beginning to look at it a
little bit more consciously Donald Trump
did a lot of that Donald Trump was the
first Republican
first major Republican presidential
candidate in my lifetime who said the
war in Iraq was a bad idea
now you might defend George Bush in the
war in Iraq you might say well he didn't
know the our intelligence told us that
that Saddam Hussein was producing
weapons of mass destruction the
intelligence Community got it wrong this
that or the other thing you might say it
was it was the right decision to be made
at the time albeit perhaps on bad
information some people I mean some of
the real hardcore neocons will still
defend it even with the bad information
but
when you when you look at the war in
Iraq
it was the United States aggressing
right
we invaded a country
based on what turned out to be a mostly
false pretext
when you look at Libya the invasion of
Libya
with the sport of NATO in Iraq and in
Libya we just invaded a country because
we didn't like what they were doing
Libya wasn't threatening the United
States Libya wasn't threatening NATO
Nations
this wasn't an article 5 Invasion we
just went in because we didn't like the
guy we invaded that country
now fast forward to the war in Ukraine
Vladimir Putin's justification for
invading Ukraine was that Ukraine is
cozying up to Nato Ukraine wants to join
NATO NATO is going to let them in by the
way that's happening now there's a major
push to let Ukraine into NATO
and there's major push to let Ukraine
into European union and all the rest of
it
and Putin said we can't tolerate this we
can't have NATO right up on our border
especially in the breadbasket of Europe
Ukraine because NATO is an aggressive
organization that seeks to harm Russia's
national interest
now all the NATO supporters said well
that's not true NATO is a defensive
Alliance we're only here to defend
ourselves we would never start a war we
would never aggress we would never
invade without a sufficient predicate
for invasion
and then vlimar Putin can point to Libya
and then flamer Putin can point to Iraq
flight reporting point to Kuwait
Vladimir Putin can point to all sorts of
places and say or Kosovo rather and say
uh no you guys have been aggressors you
guys have been a little more active than
you're pretending
to have been
and NATO doesn't have very much to say
about that
it's a healthy thing to ask every once
in a while are we the Baddies
I don't think necessarily we are you've
got to have that healthy sense and this
is why by the way the Trump side of the
GOP
scored this is why Barack Obama beat
Hillary Clinton because Barack Obama
opposed the war in Iraq Hillary still
defended the war in Iraq
there is a a major not just left or
right it's a populist
movement that is reconsidering American
foreign policy and so you've got the
many people who are opposed to foreign
adventurism
versus the elite who have a lot more
political influence than the many this
is why Tucker Carlson who's the most
prominent member was until he got fired
was the most prominent populist on cable
television and they fired him probably
because he was a little too populist
he's the most popular guy in the history
of cable news
he was the one articulating this view
maybe we shouldn't be engaging in so
much foreign adventurism
the vast majority virtually every other
talking head on TV
is advocating for a major liberal Global
Empire where we're constantly invading
every country on Earth
and then Tucker gets fired but even
though he's the most popular guy
that debate is not Republican versus
Democrat that debate is not left versus
right that debate is
the many people versus the few Elites
who have a lot of power
so when you want to take a little bit of
power for yourself reclaim a little bit
of power specifically from those car
dealerships you got to check out karzing
right now go to carzing.com Knowles
buying a new car can be a stressful
experience for everyone especially if
you're a first-time buyer or if you have
no credit before you walk onto a
dealership and spend the entire day with
crowds and stress and the potential not
even to find the right car you got to
check out carsing carsing is completely
changing the way you buy a car online by
partnering with Credit Agencies lenders
and over 25 000 dealers Nationwide
charising provides you with everything
you need before stepping foot onto a
dealership once you find the right car
at your ideal budget all you got to do
is bring your saved deal voucher with
you to the dealership to finalize your
next ride it's super duper simple even
if you're not in the market for a new
car you should check out karzing anyway
do a little online Windows shopping go
beyond mirror images dive deep into each
vehicle's specs features and performance
capabilities zoom in on the
craftsmanship of the interior your
Marvel at The Cutting Edge technology
and admire the meticulous attention to
detail that sets these automobiles apart
from the rest carzing makes the
experience faster cheaper and less
stressful go to carson.com Knowles find
the deals near you that is carzing.com
Knowles
my favorite comment yesterday is from
the drummer's Workshop Norm's music who
says the woman on that flight the woman
freaking out says you're not real you're
not real running off the flight the
woman on that flight reacted the way a
Democrat does when they see an American
flag so true such
a perspicacious incisive observation
very true speaking of explosives
Andy no the Great
antifa reporter like the one guy in the
world who's doing work to expose antifa
he showed me the criminal complaint
against the guys who tried to blow me up
in Pittsburgh
and I haven't talked too much about this
I I had a debate at Pittsburgh
this past semester I was supposed to
debate this professor McCloskey over at
gender ideology
and at the last minute he pulled out of
the debate so Brad Palumbo libertarian
journalist he comes in and we ended up
debating a kind of weaker resolution of
a similar debate it was great of Brad to
pinch hit
so that we didn't give the sensors and
the leftists and the radicals the
satisfaction of having shut down our
debate there was a ton of political
pressure to shut down this debate and
was coming from Democrats in the
legislator legislature it was coming
from the administration it was coming
from leftist students and it was coming
from outside agitators
and coming from the media also they're
trying to shut down this debate so I
show up to Pittsburgh and there's a
protest outside and you can tell already
it's it's starting to get a little
violent I go in the back way they're
setting the road on fire they're
lighting me on fire in effigy they had
an effigy of me set it on fire it was
very very odd thing first time I've ever
noticed myself being burned in effigy
very strange
I felt like Guy Fawkes you know that's
kind of nice kind of a nice honor and
then we're about to go on stage
as we're walking on stage boom
there's an explosion the cops make us go
back to the Green Room we're holding we
wait a little bit I say we're doing this
we're going on we're not letting these
jerks shut it down okay we go on stage
we have the debate
it continues to get violent outside so
they're trying to shut down the debate
before it ends we're holding firm but
the minute it ends we get off the stage
and they evacuate us pretty quickly but
we're hearing all these kind of murky
reports we didn't know exactly what was
going on they had to cancel the meet and
greet afterward it's very frustrating
because isi the group that hosted this
debate spent a lot of money on it and we
had to cancel a lot of people flew in
for it you know but we had to cancel it
because the the cops said it's it's just
not safe
well I I just read this criminal
complaint
and you know it's it's my general rule
not to whine about threats and attacks
unfortunately we're in a place in our
politics where threats and even physical
attacks just come with the territory if
you're a conservative in public life and
I don't want to I don't want to seem
like a wuss or a wimp and whine about it
all the time it comes with the territory
these days it's not right it's not just
it's just a fact so we deal with it
but this was a lot more dangerous than
than even I previously knew
the uh criminal complaint here from the
doj shows that a couple of these
anarchists who are not little kids
they're 36 years old and 40 years old as
a married couple
they
they flew in they're from Pittsburgh
they're part of an extremist cell that
meets at an anarchist Bookshop where
they train to fight people maim people
learn how to kill people uh this guy was
in Oakland another radical Hub he set
off the TSA detector for explosives for
RDX explosives and the TSA classic TSA
they just cleared him and let him get on
the plane but but
he obviously got a little bit nervous
changes the flight itinerary later on uh
sets off the TSA detector again also for
RDX explosives very serious explosives
and once again they clear them they let
him get on the plane
at approximately 7 31 PM a protester
tossed an ignited firework into a group
of approximately 12 Upp officers in the
rear of the building the firework
exploded causing injuries to several
officers three of which received unseen
evaluation by paramedics from Pittsburgh
Bureau of Emergency Medical Services one
who sought additional Care at Forbes
Hospital officers reported being burned
bruised suffering from hearing loss and
possible concussions as a result of the
explosion the device this is all from
the doj criminal complaint the device
Struck One officer fell to the ground
and then exploded into flames and debris
the the
anarchists were finally being surveilled
luckily at this big idea bookstore I
guess this is an anarchist Bookshop 4812
Liberty Avenue Pittsburgh uh
the the the individual uh one of the
individuals stated that the speaker
event my event on campus quote was not
going to happen and passed out various
zines small printed booklets to meeting
participants which instructed on how to
make incendiary devices for arson and
Molotov cocktails
the whole thing goes on I would
encourage you to read it not because of
me I survived I'm doing great luckily
the cops are doing okay I gotta give
credit to the FBI agents here and doj
really great of them especially after
we've been so uh
disappointed in recent years to see the
FBI turned political by democrats in
office and the doj selectively prosecute
conservatives let let criminal lives off
the hook really great to see the FBI in
the doj go after these guys hold them
accountable
the reason that you should consider
reading the criminal complaint is
because
this could happen to you and you just
have to be aware of it and even I I go
to 10 campuses a semester sometimes I am
very aware of this I've been attacked
previously in public
I didn't realize how serious this was
and but you should know you should know
that if you are a conservative in in any
way in public life if you're on the
school board if you show up to a meeting
if you have a protest if you have a sign
in your yard
you could be subject to Serious violence
and the libs are not just joking around
and they don't just want to throw some
glitter on you and they don't just want
to egg your house they want to kill you
they want to blow you up they want to
kill you they're dead serious about this
there is a very Sinister aspect to
what's going on here this is not just
regular political fun and games okay and
I'm not saying that to discourage you
from being politically act quite the
opposite I'm telling you that we got to
be wise as serpents and innocent as
doves and we've got to protect ourselves
because we're up against an enemy here
not just a little political opponent
we're up against an enemy that seeks our
destruction our personal destruction and
the destruction of our country
before we go there's one one story I
want to get to I meant to get to it just
after Fourth of July it's this Ben and
Jerry's story Ben and Jerry is on the
fourth of July sent out this tweet they
said this Fourth of July
it's high time we recognize that the U.S
exists on Stolen indigenous land and
commit to returning it learn more and
take action now and what's really funny
is Chief Don Stevens
chief of the nulligan band of the kusok
Abenaki Nation
told the New York Post in an interview
that Ben Jerry's exists on native land
so Ben and Jerry's should lead the
charge obviously right Ben and Jerry
should give the land back that their
corporation exists on
if you look at the traditional way of
being where place-based people he says
before recognized tribes in the state we
were the ones who were in this place
so you got to get the land back so
obviously I mean this is a funny
response by this Indian Chief and
obviously Ben and Jerry's is totally
full of it and they're Hypocrites and
they're never going to give back any
land or anything like that but the
claims of Ben and Jerry's are obviously
Preposterous too the United States does
not exist on Stolen land
uh we're not going to give it back to
anybody if we were inclined to give it
back to people we wouldn't know who to
give it to because the people who we
acquire the land from sometimes through
purchase sometimes through Conquest it's
different than stealing
but those people also acquired the land
through Conquest from other people so
you never know do you give do you give
land back in the southern part of the us
do you give it back to the Comanche
we I guess we took it from the Comanche
do you give it back to the Comanche do
you go back to the Apache the Comanche
took it from the Apache do you give it
back to the Apache or do you give it
back to the people who the Apache took
it from but it's an important reminder
that there's a difference between
stealing and Conquest the law of
Conquest has defined
geopolitics for all of human history
that's what war is Wars begins sometimes
run just reasons sometimes for just
reasons sometimes because you've got the
interests of people butting up against
one another and they're going to fight
over it
and then when when a group is conquered
that's that and one moves on this is the
this is the part of our national anthem
that we don't sing about very much
anymore but it's in this great verse you
say
and Conquer we must when our cause it is
just and this be our motto in God is our
trust
and as the political order begins to
really heat up and as our opponents
become more and more depraved and more
and more ambitious and they start coming
for us in ways that are violent that are
extreme that are totalizing they're they
want to
indoctrinate your children all the way
up to they want to re-educate the adults
they want to take your property they
want to upend your way of life and if
you don't go along with it they want to
blow you up with explosives
someone's gonna have to win
somebody's going to have to win and
somebody's going to have to lose and
I think we know which sort of spiritual
entities they're putting their trust in
and our motto ought to be in God is our
trust
conquer we must when our closet is just
all right it's Monday it's music Monday
so the rest of the show continues now
you don't want to miss it become a
member and use code Knowles kwles and
check out for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]